in 1991 frustrated by Hollywood George
decided to go back to writing novels
when no one could interfere with his
creative vision and I started actually
reading a science fiction novel that had
been an idea I've been playing with a
longtime book called Avalon and I was
working on Avalon and it was coming
pretty well and suddenly the first
chapter of Game of Thrones came to me
where they find the dire wolf pups
[Music]
it's a freak
it's a direwolf I knew it wasn't part of
the science fiction not while I was
writing this was clearly a fantasy
medieval had these wolves and this large
family I'd been reading a lot of
historical fiction am I've been in the
back of my mind but suddenly it all gels
and I wrote and I wrote that chapter in
like two three days it just came to pour
out of me don't stop there are five pups
one for each of the stark children the
direwolf is the sigil of your house
they're meant to have them will train
them yourselves you'll feed them
yourselves and if they die you will bury
them yourselves when I did return the
books I said to myself okay I've had
many things option they never make them
I've done pilots and TV shows tried to
keep them within budget and producible
and they were make that I'm tired of
playing that game I'm gonna you know I
have a big imagination I have an epic
story I want to tell I'm gonna make it
as big as my imagination I'm gonna have
all the the castles and battles I want
I'm gonna have hundreds of characters
because the real world is complex I want
my fictional world to be complex too not
as kind of simplified thing I want to
have giant battles I want to have
incredible castles that each one is
distinct from the other that people
remember for all time I want to have
dragons and dire wolves and mammoths and
a wall of ice at 700 feet tall I want
something huge and epic that can stand
up there with token
you
in 1991 disillusioned with hollywood
george RR martin embarked on a series of
epic fantasy novels called a Song of Ice
and Fire which is now reached book 5 of
a projected 7 volumes loosely based on
the Wars of the Roses it chronicles a
bloody civil war in which rival families
are fighting for the iron throne of the
Seven Kingdoms of Westeros Marge's
ambition was to create a fantasy world
as rich as Tolkien's the Lord of the
Rings when you look at something like
Lord of the Rings you're you you are
immensely impressed by the depth of the
world building encountering all those
appendices at the end of Return of the
King and you you see how much material
he has put into it
a lot of fantasy takes us lead from from
Tolkien who himself was was drawing from
older medieval myths and tradition but
most of the people who follow tokine
including me were faking it I mean
tokine was the proverbial iceberg where
you know my intense of the structure is
below the water I mean my iceberg when I
started out was some ice piled on a rest
so it gave the illusion of being iceberg
but there was nothing below the surface
from the first germ of an idea George
had to build an enormous parallel world
complete with fictional histories
religions and languages as you write the
books as you tell the stories you need
to start creating things you know some
I'm writing those that first game of
Thrones thing and you know I'm like
fifty pages into it I better I better
have a map you know I'm where's the King
coming from what's the name of the city
and what I how far is he coming I better
design a map so then at a certain point
we're referring to the Targaryen sign I
better how many Turner's were there I
better so I'm so I'm not contradicting
myself I'd better make up a list of
kings you know then I started making
names and numbers at first that's all it
was it was just vague on the first
you know one to thirty seven or whatever
and then his son and then the next son
and a list of names and numbers you add
a detail here you add a detail there and
and suddenly the world is growing or
what right alongside of your story the
world of Westeros on one level is a kind
of alternate England in the wars the
roses the map looks kind of similar to
to England and the politics is
reminiscent of the 15th century the
fairly obvious starting point is Stark
and Lannister York and Lancaster but
once you start to unpick the story you
see that there's history from just about
everywhere Roman history history of the
Crusades you look up at the wall in the
north I think that's pretty obviously a
version of Hadrian's Wall you could look
at Daenerys across the sea and you could
see her as a kind of Cleopatra or an
Amazon warrior
you've got visions of Greek history
you've got visions of South American
history ancient history modern history
all of this piled into the same world
I've got a given a stir and then on top
of that you've got this fantasy element
as well and all of this combines to
create a sort of historical fantasy
alternative world but that is very very
much of its own I always loved history
and European history more than American
history for some reason my American
history was fine you know Civil War
World War two revolution all that stuff
but there was something that maybe more
attached of the kings of England and the
Hundred Years War and the Crusades I
mean that that evoked my imagination for
some of his leading characters George
borrowed attributes from the real kings
and queens of England Edward the first
considered one of the great kings of
England but you know the more you read
about him you know the hammer of the
Scots Longshanks you know a conqueror of
Wales this is a
savage man edward ii considered a
horrible king probably the worst in
english history you like to hang out
with the common people he didn't like
jousting and swordplay what he liked he
liked carpentry and roofing fetching
rules that was his hobby and he he hung
out with carpenters and and masons and
like to learn about their building
techniques we would consider a guy like
that a pretty cool guy but it was just
unthinkable it at those times there are
times I'd like to be the king of the
world because I could you know do a few
things but most the time I'm glad I'm
not post boy that's a tough job and
being the king of anywhere is a tough
job but I like to get at that and make
the readers think about it so long as I
am your king treason shall never go
unpunished sir Ellen
bring me his head
[Applause]
when you look at a character like
Joffrey you see a caricature of the
dreadful child king but in a very
specific sense what I see is a lot of
richard ii the king who sawed off the
peasants revolt but really a vicious
horrible power-crazed young man who
turned out very very badly indeed what
constitutes a good king you know to what
extent to you do you want to be harsh
with your people to what extent do you
want to be merciful
where does justice come into it you know
Machiavelli had his views hob said his
views this is a fascinating debate and
one that said just as timely in 2015 as
it is in 1315 one King Seven Kingdoms do
you think honor keeps them in line do
you think it's honor that's keeping the
peace it's fear fear and blood he's not
writing his stories as a historian would
write them you are right down there on
the ground experiencing them looking out
through people's eyes walking there with
them and caring about them in the moment
you do that
you lost because you have to care one of
the things that sets George Martin's
fantasy world apart from other writers
is its moral complexity you are no nut
you're forsaken every vow you ever took
of so many vows they make you swear and
swear defend the King obey the King obey
your father protect the innocent defend
the weak what if your father despises
the king what if the King massacres the
innocent it's too much imagine what you
do you're forsaking one vow or another
you know it's a lot of fantasy that
concerns yourself with the Battle of
good and evil and I think the Battle of
good and evil is a is a terrific subject
for fiction but I don't think it's it's
fort between really good-looking guys in
white cloaks on white horses and really
ugly guys in black armor who smell bad
as in too much fantasy I think it's
fought within the individual human heart
I've always been attracted to gray
characters that's what I try to write
because I think those are real
characters those are real human real
human beings camera Thrones is written
entirely in a series of extremely tight
third-person viewpoints so I'm not using
first person but I'm so focused each
chapter has the name of an individual
character be it Tyrion Arya Ned whoever
it is
and during that chapter you're inside
his head you know I never go omniscient
so you're only seeing the things that he
sees you're hearing the things he hears
if something has happened in the next
room or even behind his back he's not
necessarily aware of them so you're not
aware of them mr. reader and you're
hearing the thoughts of that character
one of the most intriguing characters
George is created is Tyrion the dwarf
he is disadvantaged he is a dwarf he is
despised by his father and his sister
you are an ill-made spiteful little
creature full of envy lust and low
cunning he does have some advantages he
has a great family name he has wealth
but he's also despised largely by the
public
I wish I was the monster you think I am
I wish I had enough poison for the whole
pack of you this is person a monster is
this person a hero is it's precious
human being they're both I'm guilty of a
far more monstrous crime I'm guilty of
being a dwarf you're not on trial for
being a dwarf oh I've been in trial for
that my entire life the golden boy the
character who can have everything and do
everything and is you know the superhero
I mind is less interesting the Golden
Boy of Westeros is Jaime Lannister he's
the guy who has at all he's comes from
the most powerful family he's the
greatest swordsman in the land he's
incredibly handsome held a boy ten
the things I do for love I think we're
the perception of Jamie really changes
is suddenly when we're in Jamie's point
of view now we're seeing the world as he
sees it we're hearing his thoughts not
just the words that he speaks but the
things he doesn't say the things he's
reluctant to say his feelings that he
keeps hidden when Jamie has it hand cut
off
George manages to make us feel sympathy
well this incestuous child murderer
suddenly in a stroke he's he's crippled
he's damaged and we discover that there
are reasons for some of the things he
did and we discover his his doubts and
his failings and his temptations and his
justifications and all of that helps to
helps to humanize him George has also
created a number of complex female
characters struggling to survive in a
brutal male world it has also been
criticized for portraying women as too
subservient to men's desires
well women's options in the world of
Westeros in particularly as 1700
Westeros are relatively limited as they
were again for for much of Western
history you know Western history is very
long you know women had one role in
ancient Greece and even there it was
different and smarter than it was in
Athens and you know then the Macedonians
said we're still different and then the
Romans came in and they had this so it's
always changing
and the Middle Ages itself is a thousand
years long from you know the fall of
Rome to the Renaissance and during that
thousand years there were great
differences according to country and
according to time in the status accorded
to women medicine was not far advanced
to a tremendous men and women who died
in childbirth
highborn women had had more advantages
but in some ways also more disadvantages
they were more likely to be sold or for
a political marriage and you know oh
good I have a daughter I can marry him
you know my twelve-year-old daughter to
the 75 year old guy in the next county
and hopefully get his land Middle Ages
were not a kindly time for women now
that's not to say that it was true of
all women there were certainly powerful
women and terah's mennick when
but unless it was these were not
egalitarian centuries
the fate of George's characters and the
moral choices they make has provoked
huge online debate among George's
readers the fact that there are such
vigorous debates going on there it's an
indication to me that I'm doing doing
something right you know when when
people are debating vigorously about
whether a character is a good person or
a bad person that shows you created a
real character because then they're
debating about that person the same way
we in real life debate about President
Obama or Winston Churchill or Neville
Chamberlain or you know real characters
from history or from the current world
you know if everybody thinks your
character's a hero or everybody thinks
your character's villain and you're
writing cardboard
George RR Martin's A Song of Ice and
Fire was launched as a TV series Game of
Thrones in 2011 it's time to the biggest
and most expensive television series in
the world George likes to host free
marathon screenings of the series at the
cinema in Santa Fe which he recently
bought to say from closure this is just
good storytelling it is it is everything
horrible about humanity that we're not
supposed to enjoy but really is kind of
enjoyable to watch
it's a fantasy world that's he's sort of
the direwolf representative in the real
world here I think it's a wonderful
political allegory I think it's
absolutely about the misuse of power mr.
Marquis has been a great citizen he's
given us a lot
I love old movie theaters for me that's
part of the experience of going to a
film I know the generation coming up
likes to get Netflix and watch them on
their cell phones but for me that's not
the experience I want I want to see my
movies on a big screen and a movie
theater and with a crowd around me
sitting in the dark and ideally with
some buttered popcorn and a soft drink
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I'm a big fan of television and
film but I never thought a Song of Ice
and Fire could be done when I was
starting it out and it was almost
deliberate
then when Peter Jackson adapted the Lord
of the Rings trilogy for the big screen
he demonstrated that epic fantasy could
be brought to life using modern
cinematic techniques and digital
wizardry the films were massive global
hit and Hollywood is basically imitative
so you know if a movie about a clown
does well everybody wants a movie about
a clown epic fantasy had done well
suddenly every studio in Hollywood was
looking for their own Lord of the Rings
George received a lot of offers to turn
his books into a movie but they all
wanted to simplify the story
it took Peter Jackson three movies to
make Tolkien's Lord of the Rings he
still had to cut things it would take
three movies for long storm swords alone
and if you figure like two movies for
Game of Thrones and two movies for Clash
of Kings you're already you're already
up to seven movies and and your behalf
way through the series nobody's going to
commit to that and of course they
wouldn't commit to that the people I met
with from movies said one of two things
they either said oh we'll just make the
first movie and then after that's a hit
then we'll make more well of course if
you go down that route then you have
Philip Pullman's His Dark Materials
great fantasy they made the first movie
didn't do as well as they expected
you'll never see the second movie you
never see the third movie so I didn't
like the idea of that broken kind of
series or alternatively they said well
we have to find yes it's true it's too
complexes to a big way it is but we have
to find the the central art and we've
decided the central arc is Jon Snow but
the whole movie would be about Jon Snow
or the central park is Daenerys no movie
will be about the same job princess and
she gives birth to dragons and that's
that's where he will be about that might
be a good movie that would be
interesting but it wouldn't be my story
my story is a combination of stuff and I
was in a fortunate position because you
know I'd worked in Hollywood I didn't
live an extravagant lifestyle I'd saved
my money I'd paid off my debts and now I
had a best-selling serious it was
bringing in a lot of money I didn't need
the money so I could head to power to
say the sexiest word in Hollywood No
no thanks appreciate the offer but no no
don't think we want to do it but
George's books found our way into the
hands of two young producers it's
something different in mine I started
reading and got to the scene where bran
has pushed out the window and I thought
wouldn't see that coming and got a few
hundred pages more into it and called
Dan who was an old friend and we went to
graduate school together and I knew that
he also grew up reading fantasy and and
said I might be losing my mind but I
think this is the most fun I've had
reading a book and have been in as long
as I can remember he brought us back to
that experience of compulsive reading
that we had when we were were kids where
you would sit in a comfortable chair for
eight hours read to 300 pages in a
sitting by kind of grafting adult
psychological reality onto a genre that
was so formative for us so it was a
potent combination that he did he pulled
off so deftly and you know not just once
but again and again and again Benioff
and Weiss saw the potential to turn
George's novels not into a film but into
a television series for the
groundbreaking American cable channel
HBO what he does with his genre is very
similar to what HBO has been doing to
the genres with the gangster genre the
Western the history and and the cop show
like it's what they've been doing for
years it's of the shows that they made
that have kind of ushered in the golden
age of television if the books are full
of sex they're full of battles that full
of violence none of which is ever going
to pass the network censors HBO was
definitely the place to be I mean The
Sopranos
Deadwood room you know incredible shows
dark shows powerful shows shows with
violence social so switch sexes wet
sexuality they would get behind a
project and they would give it a solid
commitment we'd never produced anything
for television before we're never
produced anything for film or internet
or
anything we'd written before but we
never produced so when we went to George
probably it was kind of like it was
probably like that Bluff where you
mistakenly think you have a straight and
you actually don't but we were so
confident that that I think we convinced
George that well these guys seem like
they really know what they're doing I
said I want it done I want a faithful
adaptation in the books and I said
that's what we want to do and we had
just a great lunch we talked for hours
to lunch turned into dinner George
tested Benioff and Weiss his knowledge
of his books with an obscure question
about the character of Jon Snow and he
got the sort of you know the shrewd look
on his face and he said so who is Jon
Snow his mother and oddly luckily Danna
I've been talking about this the night
before and we didn't know but we had
theory about it so we kind of looked at
each other and then one of us said the
answer that we thought and she didn't
say yes or no but he got this little
smile and then you know the next we
heard was George has approved your you
know your bid or whatever you call it so
at the end of it I said okay yeah I'll
I'll give it to you go take it go take
it into HBO and run with it Game of
Thrones is not the most popular and the
most expensive television series in the
world it has a cast of thousands and is
filmed on location in Iceland Spain
Malta Croatia
and Northern Ireland George RR Martin's
vision as a global appeal
I don't know whether George is
channeling the zeitgeist or George has
changed the zeitgeist but I think it's
very true
he's part of the reasons the book the
books and the series have become so
popular it obviously speaks to the way a
lot of people feel we've talked to
people from Russia people from Brazil
people certainly in the States and you
hear it's really it's like Game of
Thrones here and it's like the
government is just like Game of Thrones
and I've heard that applied to Putin
I've heard it applied to Assad and Syria
I've heard it applied to you know
Republican politicians here and it's
just it's just everywhere but there's a
problem now the TV series is caught up
with the novels and George is nowhere
near finishing the sixth volume luckily
we've had a lot of talks with George
about where he's going we know the end
point and we're hoping that um you know
that end point will be very much in
keeping with the spirit of the books my
very first deadline on Game of Thrones I
blew fairly spectacular Lee and I've
been blowing every deadline I wouldn't
give him her sense there's always nine
more things to do there's always
pressure to write the next script or
finish the next season or go on a
promotional tour and it's it it keeps me
busy
fans of George's books I mean getting
increasingly impatient websites and
blogs have appeared angrily demanding
that he hurries up and completes the
series as early as 2009 his friend and
fellow writer Neil Gaiman famously came
to his defense I told the world george
RR martin is not your [ __ ] and it
turned up much to my surprise on
t-shirts on badges somebody even wrote a
george RR martin is not your [ __ ] song
[Music]
your deal with meadow or when you buy
his book is not that he will spend every
waking moment of his life writing
another book for you to read I'll deal
with you as an implicit one and it is
that the book that you bought will be a
good book
I've given up making predictions as to
when I'm gonna finish it because every
time I do I'm wrong and you know then
everybody gets all bent out of shape
about it I'm writing the winds of winter
which is book six in the series and I
hope the next to last book the last book
will be a dream of spring once those are
done then I can take a rest and enjoy a
few of the accolades and the fruits of
success that have accumulated to me and
then go back to writing something or
other and I'll be a different person
that in the world will have changed and
I'll see what I feel like writing and
whatever year that happens to be I
should be doing that right now you're
interfering with me I'm sure this book
will be a year late just because of you
[Laughter]